the jurogan experience you and i would
have met
eight years ago just about to the date
in a few months because
it will be the eight year anniversary of
my
being sued by marine land of canada for
plotting to steal a walrus
which would have been in february of
2013.
it's been so long i hardly remember how
we
were introduced i can tell you the story
please do
when i was sued by marineland the
headlines uh international were quite
absurd
one of which in the uh said the kanye
west of animal training gets sued for
1.5
and i tweeted to you saying dude they're
calling me the kanye west of animal
training he's like they're calling you
the what
and then you went straight to my dm you
said dude you got to come to l.a and we
got to talk about this i'm like dude i'm
on the next flight let's do it well i've
always had a soft spot in my heart for
dolphins and orcas and and i just i
think we're going to look at i've said
this before on the podcast with you but
i think we're going to look at in the
future the same way we look at slavery
i think they're it makes me sad just
talking about it
i think i think they're as intelligent
as we are
i think they're just different and
because we don't understand their
language
we uh we think it's okay and i think
it's it's beyond [ __ ] up
watching your documentary made me cry
man it made me really cry when i was
watching that dolphin get force-fed
god damn that's hard when they're
holding his mouth open and shoving fish
in his throat
i'm like [ __ ] christ what what is
that imagine
a person imagine a person i mean you're
dealing with an animal that has a
cerebral cortex that's 40
larger than a person's can i tell you
the story of that animal his name was
sam he came in an old male dolphin
wild caught from russia and when we
received him
you only had to take one look and
realize this animal is going to reject
captivity
he's a [ __ ] warrior he's got scars up
and down this is not an animal that's
going to accept being told what to do by
idiots like me and you just saw he
rejected captivity we did everything we
could to keep him alive and you know
if you notice in the documentary i was
told to turn the camera off
and i said no no this is important i
knew then
that a lot of the documentation of the
things that i was taking
could prove useful in the future i
didn't have an agenda when i was there
remember i was a company guy
i i well you were a kid and i was a kid
that's what's crazy
about your documentary the walrus and
the whistleblower getting emotional
already
i know i came to the right place joe
you've always been the biggest support
and the fact that you answer all my
calls you're one of the last
and uh i just know i'm in the right
place this is my safe place and uh
thank you for that well i've invested
i'm invested in you
and your thing in this this this project
and the fact that
canada stepped up and made all orca
and dolphin captivity illegal and that
doesn't exist without you and i having
had done this
it it the the back story to that is it
was an interview of with you and i
where the senator's son approached the
center and said is there any way we can
help this guy
and then suddenly a private member's
bills was introduced you know i got a
call saying hey we're looking to work on
something here
and i was like absolutely and that's how
the bill got drafted it doesn't exist
without you and i haven't spoken so
in every which way i have you to thank
and the world over has you to thank
because the
influence that you have had on the
passing of this law and now it's
progressing to other countries other
countries are consulting with i'm
actually
being witnessed in australia i submitted
some uh uh witness uh testimony what not
to to to support
the a similar ban and also
i'd like to take the opportunity to take
this time to say that there's more laws
coming in canada
the next law that's been introduced by
the same senator uh
uh senator murray sinclair who's
actually
retiring but he now has introduced
what's called the jane goodall act
which is now going to extend animal
protections and ban the captain of great
apes
big cats because there's you know
there's some places in ontario in canada
that are awful that they just breed
these cats rapidly it's just
it's just not the place to have them
they're riding elephants at a place
called uh
african lion safari you're next anyways
laws are coming so
joe in every which way that i get
attributed with having done all this
stuff i attribute it right back to you
that's the influence of this show i knew
something eight years ago
when i was desperate and looking for a
place to to
where i can speak unimpeded the media
doesn't allow me that
with the lawsuits and everything on me a
lot of places won't talk to me
because they get threatened to be sued
you kept talking to me and so we're here
today
in celebration of every which way that
you have influenced both my life and the
way that we can continue to influence
uh uh the state of the [ __ ] planet
for these
majestic animals i mean really it
doesn't take a lot of thinking
to realize that dolphins porpoises and
whales have like you say a higher
intelligence i'll even challenge to
suggest that they may be even more
emotionally intelligent than we could
ever appreciate
i mean there's a chance that they're
more intelligent than us so
you know when you say that what watching
that dolphin get force-fed
i have 12 years of that to process and
to discuss and to talk and
it's invaluable that my experience that
i have these open channels to speak
and i have them because of you so well
thank you joe
i'm honored and i'm happy and you you've
been here
i mean if we're going back eight years
this is literally the beginning of the
podcast when it was just
you were one of like the first groups of
interviews because i was just kind of
talking [ __ ] with my friends most of the
time back then episode 425
it didn't have um i mean it wasn't it
didn't have an impact on culture it was
just a
silly thing that we were doing and so
to talk to you about something that
meant something to me
and for to see that you've been just
[ __ ] swinging
duking it out all these years and when
you watch the documentary you get a real
sense of
how long this has been a part of your
life it's crazy goosebumps you've even
got the
you're even rocking the glasses old man
style now i bought these you've been
coming on forever and now you're rocking
i'm so gray now
you're rocking glasses like this it's
it's really nuts man when
when you look at the the overall time
spent
battling this out i can't think of
another person that's more on the
forefront
of uh marine mammal captivity than you
are
and again i have for you to thank for
all of that um listen i have you to
thank
i wouldn't have i would just been just
talking [ __ ]
about it i would i mean i i never
thought that it would have an impact
i didn't you know it wasn't a plan
i knew the second you dm'd me i thought
this is it this is my chance and then
years went by and it occurred to me i'm
gonna have to go again this doesn't end
and i came back and then the bills start
piling up again
and then i got to come back this is now
the fifth time i've been here joe i will
say this that's crazy i will say this
you have the most influential podcast in
the world the fact that i've had to come
here five times will tell you just
how much abuse that it is that i've
endured systematic abuse through both
the courts
you know marineland's lawyer andrew
burns is
really good at doing what he does which
is
abuse the system and you know by virtue
of
i'm still here accruing inordinate
amounts of
of debt for a lawsuit that can easily be
be uh resolved it's a trespassing uh
lawsuit
i never i never stepped foot on the
property there isn't an iota of evidence
that i've been presented in a
multi-million dollar lawsuit against me
that i'm able to defend against
there's nothing it's all fiction they're
literally created a [ __ ] story about
me and are using the courts to in every
which way
silence me and what's crazy is during
this time the owners died
from the time you came in the podcast
way back eight years ago till now
the owner's now dead the guy that you
were calling out
on the podcast back then and the guy
who's in the documentary you see him and
you you see his
just his demeanor and his attitude and
everything about it it's just
and now the fact that he's gone but yet
the lawsuit rages on
and that's what screams that this is now
personal
lawyers their reputation is everything
marineland's lawyer
thought this would go away a long time
ago because it's not and because i've
taken a lot of
options away from him as i continue down
this very long
process i think he's getting nervous a
little bit
this has become a hallmark lawsuit in
canada a lot of eyes are on
on what he's doing and there's going to
be a lot more after this and in a lot of
ways he's making himself famous for all
the
wrong [ __ ] reasons but i'm happy to
be on the show to help make that happen
but there's no good side
to keeping those animals in captivity
there's no good side to be running a
place like marineland there's no
there's no upside it's i mean the video
alone if you watch the documentary
the video alone of the the damage their
skin
when they're using chlorine and seeing
those animals bleeding and
seeing those animals getting force-fed
there's no defending it
you can't defend that it's not and we
have this concept of intelligence based
on our own ability to manipulate the
environment around us
our concept of intelligence is based on
our ability to build things
and drive a car and fly a plane and
that's how we
equip we we need to see manipulation in
order to
to to believe that it's intelligent life
but these animals speak in a way that
they've been
i mean lily was trying to decipher
dolphin intelligence in the 1960s
they still don't know what the [ __ ]
they're saying they've determined that
there's some sort of
they have dialects and they have they
have
different accents for different regions
but they don't know what they're saying
they still don't these are insanely
intelligent animals
i don't want to i don't want to say give
up on the idea of interpreting language
necessarily but the idea that we can
attribute words to their sounds is just
not
it's not the thing to do and again i'm
not going to take anything away from
scientists or doing this of course but
i can i can attest that in my experience
being there the things that i took note
of
in in terms of how they communicated i
can tell you when a dolphin was sad
angry excited all of these things i can
tell you
i mean i can i can attribute what i
believe that to have been now in my
experience
yeah i would say that that holds true
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience